es el la leyenda del rock million quien
inició el movimiento cuando se retiró de
spotify
pronto le siguieron otros artistas como
la cantante canadiense joni mitchell y
es que todos critican a la plataforma
por albergar los podcasts de joe rogan
un presentador estadounidense acusado de
difundir información falsa sobre la
pandemia y las vacunas contra el kobe 19
desde hace días el boicot ha ido en
aumento hasta que finalmente daniel es
el director de spotify reaccionó el
domingo anunciando varias medidas en un
comunicado me quedó claro que teníamos
la obligación de hacer más de
proporcionar equilibrio y acceso a la
información ampliamente aceptada de las
comunidades médicas y científicas
ni sanciones ni exclusiones están
previstas los planes van hacia la
información con tres medidas en primer
lugar se emitieran las normas de
publicación de la compañía y serán
accesibles para todos los usuarios en
segundo lugar los enlaces a la
información científica estarán en todos
los podcasts que hablen de kobe 19 y por
último esperan encontrar una forma para
que los creadores de contenidos sean
conscientes de lo que es aceptable o no
pero esta tarea parece especialmente
complicada
aunque la dificultad es que la industria
del podcast está muy descentralizada
with one no hay realmente una plataforma
ni una persona que pueda dirigir la
moderación de los contenidos y subir en
marketing sin embargo a medida que
spotify ve cómo aumenta su contenido
también crece la responsabilidad
editorial de la plataforma y la
moderación de los mismos se está
convirtiendo en un tema importante al
igual que para redes sociales como
facebook twitter o instagram